okay so I am much older than my coworker
err
but sometimes that just means I'm much
wiser for example Eric thought they were
you just sitting in Paris Hilton
invented the selfie she aimed oh my god
yes look ah huh eleven years ago today a
Casselton and Brittany invented the
selfie pair there's a new selfie but in
2004 the movie 13 going on 30 came out
and that movie has two scene where they
take a selfie
I have never even heard of that movie so
I gotta show to you that's a camera
though that's like a selfie from 2004 so
I was doing work and now you got me
invested in this and I need to know like
who actually and then meant to the first
cell I need you to find this ten minutes
baby
wait you're watching a movie yeah it's
really good
[Music]
I had to find out who invented the
selfie I mean I work at BuzzFeed so it's
like my job to do that it's not my job
to do that specifically but I made it my
job today at least so I called
BuzzFeed's resident selfie expert hey
jazz hey taking selfies is like really
important to make sure that you're
confident when you do it because you
know everybody's gonna be seeing this
yeah you want to make sure you find some
good lighting yeah I'm so good you like
your background or like contrast with
your background you don't like play off
the colors so who invented the selfie um
I would assume Paris Hilton but I'm not
sure that's not who really invented it
like who really invented the selfie like
the first person is that what you wanted
to know the whole time yeah literally
just google it just go on typing your
little keyboard super selfie so I
decided to Google it turns out there's
not really a definitive answer at least
not on the first like two pages of my
Google search results not only did Paris
Hilton have nothing to do with inventing
a selfie she didn't even coined the term
the first documented use of the term
selfie at least in print was in
September 2002 when a user hopi posted a
close-up of his busted lip writing I had
a hole about one centimeter long right
through my bottom lip and sorry about
focus it was a selfie krishnan GC my
slack
it's the first selfie all right that's
not something it doesn't look like a
selfie as we know it but cuz just the
lips but I okay so
Hopi himself says it was not a word I
coin it's something that was just come
slang at the time used to describe a
picture of yourself okay well then who
coined the term coining it is different
than invented thinking about like
artists for centuries were doing
self-portraits it sounds like before the
fifteen hundreds shoulda paid attention
in art class according to James Hall
people in the 15th century were
manipulating their self images sometimes
making themselves appear younger and
sometimes casting themselves in biblical
roles because branding is after all the
second oldest profession more so than
hope is busted lip these self-portraits
with their manipulated images capture
the spirit of the selfie Albrecht Durer
a self-portrait issed and a well-known
narcissist used to paint himself with
long flowing hair to appear more
christ-like although his actual
appearance is more reminiscent of a guy
from the early 90s with over plucked
eyebrows and permed hair but honestly
what's wrong with a little selfie
manipulation when I post a selfie my
teeth are white my eyes are big and my
nose is practically non-existent
I'm basically a Bratz doll Rembrandt
Courbet van Gogh they all painted
selfies sadly a few hours into the
middle of my research I hit a bit of a
snag it's between Rembrandt
Courbet and Bango we're going to do that
we have to figure out if like paintings
are selfies I don't look at a definition
of what is healthy yeah I looked at of
course I liked the definition so what it
were to say I didn't look at a
definition all right so
all right good according to Oxford it is
a photograph that one is taken in
oneself typically with a smart phone or
webcam and uploaded to a social media
website a selfie has to be a photo
everything I've done to this point has
been pointless yeah how much time we're
gonna have to time travel forward a
couple hundred years to the invention of
the camera the first partially
successful images were produced around
1816 by neesee for neeps but those
negatives didn't even last long he used
silver chloride which darkens when
exposed to light those images
disappeared he was basically the
nineteenth-century snapchat so we can't
really say for sure whether nisa for
needs took that first selfie because we
don't have the photos anymore the
Library of Congress believes the first
selfie taken in America was a
photographic portrait by Robert
Cornelius in 1839 Robert had to hold
still for 15 minutes to get the perfect
selfie which is not too different than
how long it takes to get the perfect
selfie today since we take like 80
photos on average maybe a hundred we got
the answer yeah come here that's my man
Robert C from Philly and he took the
first selfie in America and that's it
right there
where's the camera well he he had to
like set it and then had to run around
and go he did selfie sticks were not
that was not a thing used the new
Instagram filter and like took Craig he
didn't call the collodial wet plate
that's the filter Harris Holton is not
even the first celeb selfie because
Anastasia Romanov took that in 1914 so
she invented the self Rob Tilley yeah
well I wouldn't say he invented the
selfie either
because actually this selfie isn't
really an invention it's a phenomenon
the inventor isn't a particular person
it's the internet social media our own
vain narcissistic selves and goddammit
we don't want to waste our time waiting
for someone else to take it we can take
the photo our goddamn selves so who
invented the selfie
it's you you invented the selfie uh-huh
no stop I don't want it I didn't invent
the selfie I don't want to start any
drama
you like capital you like Raiders sense
yes yeah thank you like
yeah humanity we all did together it's
like a phenomenon it's not a person
isn't that is that the ending of this
you just cop that it felt deep was
revenue yeah yes for a video we are
running out of ideas
oh my god okay I guess I didn't really
answer the question I just made 20 bucks
off Bitcoin
[Music]